i remember as uh i started to get older
and i was running with um
the neighborhood uh so-called gangsters
we'll call them gangsters and thugs for
right now
uh sometimes when i would uh like smoke
weed or something
i would get this uh funny feeling um
like everybody was looking at me or
staring at me
and uh you know i just i just felt like
i didn't belong i just felt like i
didn't know
what i was uh there for and sometimes a
couple of them would look at me and like
dude are you all right or you and one
time a friend of mine asked me was i gay
i said are you gay
and it's because i get this real shy
look i guess when i uh
you know just be confronted with around
a lot of people
and i didn't really i knew how to answer
it i'm like no
but at the same time um i just didn't
know what was going on and why would i
have to have these feelings as i um
grew older about my uh my manhood
because of what happened to me because i
know it wasn't my fault
what happened and uh but it plays on
your mind as you grow older
you know you just don't know and uh i
didn't tell anyone i didn't tell my
mother
my father not a soul so this is
something i had to live with
and once i hit skid row
and i came down here i think it was a
couple of years
two or three years and because of my
addiction to drugs
i was over by uh negotia park
and uh there was this guy there who had
just got a lawsuit
and um he came on the streets with
another guy and i noticed they kept
staring at me
and one of them came and approached me
and asked me did i want to go get high
with him and i said yeah
and uh just so happened the guy had a
few thousand dollars on him he went and
got a motel
and the guy continued to proposition me
and he wanted
um me to have sex with him
and uh i was afraid i wouldn't even have
any more to drugs or whatever or they
put me out
so i uh did just so happened after this
happened
uh about two weeks later the guy came
down he happened to know my wife at the
time
and he told her and i can't tell you
what i had to go through with that one
right there
i think it was a couple of years after
that that i uh
continued downtown l.a i came worked my
way back down here
and there happened to be an old man he
happened to be
uh had to be at least 15 years older
than anybody else but he would circle
the streets i didn't know what he was
doing that time
at the time but he would walk the
streets and he would look for young men
and he'd take him back up to his room
and he'd buy them all the drugs they
want
to have sex with him and uh
i would do this any time he asked me to
come up to his room
and um i
i was the type of person with drugs when
it came to my drugs i didn't care
uh i i was going to have him one way the
other
and i think one time when i went up to
his room one of somebody had gotten wind
of it and came downstairs and told
everyone else that knew me
uh that i was coming out this guy's room
and so there came a lot of negative
energy because of that
a lot of people want to label me a lot
of people want to
talk about me and i just dealt with it
i didn't think bad of myself i just had
to deal with it
you know sometimes that's hard because
it's uh
it's something i've been dealing with
all my life and i'm not saying i'm i've
been dealing with
am i straight or gay i'm saying i've
been dealing with uh
people who don't know me labeling me and
not really knowing me
and i've been dealing with the streets
of la and i can't tell you how many
times
down here that i was constantly
approached
by a lot of people men and women
um sometimes if the man wasn't
too uh disrespectful as far as his
approach
then there was no problem with me and
sometimes if they were disrespectful
like talking on
my clothes and stuff then i wouldn't uh
do anything with them you know because
you were disrespecting me
and this is something that i continued
to go through
downtown and um i can i can say this
about it
i never really cared one way or the
other
about what anyone thought because i knew
where it stemmed from it's still from my
childhood
and it's something i had to deal with
all my life so
what someone else thought of me never
really mattered
and um i remember one time i had uh
one in this guy's room and he had a girl
there and he had uh
another man there and we were all three
just having sex she didn't care and i
knew the girl from the streets
she didn't care the guys didn't care and
it was my first time doing that
and i'm not going to say i really
enjoyed it because there were too many
people there
for me to be happy about doing anything
like that
but it's something i also participated
in and um
this has been something ongoing you know
just the sex in my life downtown and
sometimes i wonder
is it just um the atmosphere down here
you know where all everything is okay
down here nobody really
questions too much um
where you go and what you do so it's
almost like it's acceptable
down here to be whoever you want to be
and um i don't i don't know what to say
about it except that uh
i have to deal with it every day i want
a better life for myself and i
just continue to have to go through
things like that
um i think one time a guy even drugged
me
i had went into his room and uh i know i
wasn't tired that night because i went
to sleep the day before
and um when i woke up
later i i believe he had drugged me
because i woke up not knowing where i
was and i thought i was in a
a rehabilitation or a program i didn't
even recognize the guy when i looked
over at him i thought he was a guy in
the program
and i spoke for a minute and i must have
dozed back off
then i woke up again and i was naked
and i looked around and i said where in
the hell are my clothes at
and i said why would this person take my
clothes off and i'm in a program
why am i in a program but naked
and um i
i just kept dozing back off and waking
up and when i woke up the last time i
asked
i had to ask the guy then did you drug
me or something and he said uh he didn't
and i asked him why is it you have your
clothes off and i have my clothes off
and he said well i was tired or
something and he had just
i fell asleep so he had just addressed
me
um i truly don't believe that i truly
believe when he did undress me he
undressed me to have sex with me
uh i don't remember too much but i can't
think of another reason why anyone would
undress you and you wake up in their
house but naked
you know um after that
[Music]
i really really wanted to uh beat this
guy's ass because i didn't know what had
happened but i had no proof of anything
i had no proof that i was drugged i had
no proof of anything so i just
uh got up the next morning and i left
um several episodes like that
downtown not that happened just to me
but that i hear other people talking
about
you know things that they have to go
through you know just trying to survive
down here
um sometimes i feel it's necessary
you know to have money to eat or uh
you know a drug of my choice or whatever
and sometimes i don't it's basically
according to how
that day is going you know how i feel
about
what i'm going to do uh i think i'm uh
lucky so far unless not to have a
disease
um i remember i used to get magazines or
a phone i don't think i even viewed porn
until i was in my 30s
and it seemed to be the okay thing down
here i would
sometime pass guys on the streets and
just on the
propped up against a building looking at
a porn magazine
uh some of them may even be masturbating
i would look around another corner as
another day and there's a man and a
woman having sex
on the streets so all of this um
just seemed the part of things that were
okay to do
so once i adapted to the porn this
became my outlet
you know i would uh
buy me porn magazines i remember one
time i had a backpack and i had to have
at least 10 of them in there
it was just part of my high to get high
and looking porn
and then when the cell phones came out
of i did the same thing with them
porn just became a part of my life and a
part of uh
the high you know just getting high
and looking at porn became something i
would do every day and i kind of think
that saved me in a sense
because um i had gotten addicted to the
porn just like i did
to drugs i believe and uh what that did
that stopped me from having so much sex
you know with people it's and i think it
saved me from having
diseases and stuff like that
um there's just so much
that goes on in a person's life down
here i can't tell you how many times i'm
uh caught
in a precarious situation uh with a with
a man
or a woman by people that had respect
for me
and maybe still do some and um
and what i mean by caught is maybe in a
tent
or maybe just walking down the streets
and most people down here know the uh
you know the ins and outs and what
you're normally going to do
and um sometimes a person would uh say
something about me sometimes the person
would say something to me
and uh it was really none of their
business you know
and i i would either lie about it
or i would um tell them the truth
i remember one time a guy uh drove me
all the way to the valley
from downtown l.a and once we got there
he uh
put out a drug really that wasn't my
choice
and uh just to show you how important
that is sometimes the sex and the drugs
i um i did the drug
which was crystal but i did to crystal
and i
had sex and i did everything else as if
it was something else
my job of choice and um
i have to be honest i kind of enjoyed it
you know um
but it it's not something i would like
you know the crystal and the drugs all
the time with that
um i've had sex with people
sometimes even though i didn't want to i
felt taken advantage of sometimes
what i mean by that is um i think i'm a
mellow guy
and some people are more um to me in
this
crazy stuff or different stuff when it
comes to the sex
and uh sometimes i would just go along
with it
and sometimes i would um
you know i've just done so much as far
as uh
my uh my sexual uh content down here
and how i would go about having sex and
who i would have sex with
and and i'm just hoping that one day i
can find out who i really am
and and just do uh me
and and not have to worry about uh doing
anything because i want a drug
i want to get high and so
any and everything else goes i've heard
people say that
and confess in a meeting before what
they've done
because they believe this is going to
clear their uh
i don't know conscience or soul so
they're they're telling i had sex with a
man or a woman to say i had sex with a
woman
in a meeting i don't i don't think
that's necessary and i've never done
that
i don't think it's anyone's business and
i don't think it'll make me feel any
better or worse
to uh admit it you know
this is just who i am and it really
doesn't matter to me what the next
person thinks you know
i go through it every day you know
sometimes i don't
have to uh worry about if i feel guilty
or if i feel
good sometimes i just go along with it
and um sometimes i like it
sometimes i don't you know it's it's uh
like i said it's a feeling with the
drugs
and the sex is a feeling that i can't uh
always turn away sometimes i'm just used
to having
the two together instead of the one and
it becomes boring
with just the one if i'm sitting
anywhere just doing drugs a lot of times
without sex
that's um a boring feeling to me you
know
it's nothing to it to the point to where
i almost um
i almost couldn't see having one without
the other i can i can almost feel it
where it's like i i did not like getting
high
without having sex it just was like the
two went together
and uh i think probably in the last
few months i started to realize
well neither one is good for you neither
one is good for me
and um you know i'ma have to
tame one maybe to get rid of the other i
don't know
but i i know it's a thought that crosses
my mind
all the time on how i'm going to live my
life
and sexually
and and downtown on skid row you know i
just want things to uh work out no
matter
what choices i choose in life you know i
just want things to continue to go
the way i uh it should go for me
as there's there has been times down
here where um
people have been real uh
just open with it you know i remember i
passed these guys once
and you could tell they were all uh gay
and they asked the guy in front of me
to strip down butt naked and show him
his body and he would they would give
him um
twenty dollars and the guy did it
and uh i was like wow man is
is it really that important to me where
i would actually do that if they asked
me and i didn't think so
i really didn't think i would just take
my clothes off on the streets in public
you know for a 20 bill um
because uh some guys wanted to see my
body
sometimes it's hard talking about this
you know sometimes it's not
and you know it's it's something i dealt
with
um i had a cousin
well he he was like a cousin he was gay
he was older than me
and i remember i went to his house and
uh
to visit my other cousin my other cousin
left and went somewhere
and uh the older cousin offered me a
drink and i took the drink
and uh then he asked me if he could uh
have oral sex with me and i
pulled out my thing then i let him and
like i said sometimes it's just the high
and the
uh the sex together and this is one of
the first times i had done that
and um i remember i had stopped it for
years down here
and then one day this little guy comes
up little short guy
stays pretty sharp and uh
he asked me was that my tent and i said
yeah
and he asked me if he could come in and
he'd get me high and i said yeah and he
came in
and as we started getting high he
started filling on me but what was weird
about this guy
was that as he got high and he
grinded his butt on my uh private area
he would whisper he would make these
sounds and he would just
say things to me that almost sound
sounded unnatural you know it was like
he turned into somebody else
uh i don't know if you guys believe him
like he turned into a demon or something
you know he would just grab grind and
whisper and
i was like what the heck man but that
was his eye
that was just his way of getting off i
guess and uh
he was one of the first ones
down here in years and years um that i
had actually uh went there with again
and it turned out the guy was a pretty
cool guy you know
i think he's from chicago or something
like that but he uh
was a pretty cool guy he kept money and
kept his thing going and we wouldn't see
each other all the time but
sometimes if he did we did and once
again i'm hard up for drugs and here
this guy comes
and he'd have a lot of money in drugs
then it would be no problem with me
so my thing is sometimes is that right
or is it wrong
you know or or is it is it even my fault
i
i don't know you know and
should i care because
like i said i i don't care sometimes i
feel like
i uh brad pitter denzel washington down
here
because everybody has something to say
you know it's i don't know if it's the
negative energy downtown
or if if there is negative energy or if
it's just me
but the bottom line is i don't really
care what anyone has to say
this is a problem that i have to work
out for myself if
even if it is a problem and this is
something i have to go through
and uh i do it every day you know
and i and i have to say the only thing
that i'm really
um believing that i need to get rid of
is the drugs because that's the uh
problem that is what stops me from
escalating and becoming
whoever i can become it's not so much
the uh
the sex it's the drugs and if i can if i
can just
lift the drugs and all you know
i believe i'd probably be more happier
no matter what type of sexual happening
you know um the drugs are the ones that
probably bring on
all these other feelings and doubt
uh that have to go with my uh
my problems as a kid that i went through
sometimes i'm ashamed that i never told
my mother or my father all right i'm not
going to say a shame sometimes i think
i should have told one of them at an
early age
what was going on because it went on
more than once
you know it just went on whatever
uh my grandfather felt like it
and i never told nobody but i don't
think i told anybody because at that
time
i didn't know if anything was wrong i
didn't even know what he was doing was
wrong
i didn't i don't think i really knew
right from wrong when it came to that
so what was there to tell you know you
don't you don't start realizing
something is wrong until you get older
and then you start hey wait a minute
that wasn't right um
but by then i clammed up
it became a secret my own my secret
and it's something i live with every day
um like i said downtown it's just a
different uh
lifestyle and i've adapted with it and
to it
and uh i'm not gonna say downtown is the
only place that i've ever uh had those
feelings
because it's not you know i i have been
in other places
and i have done other things uh i
remember one time uh
i think i was 15 years old and
two of my older friends they were older
than me
i went to get my hair did at the uh
beauty shop or the barber shop
where they got their hair did at and
there was this big black african guy the
one that would
do the hair and um
as he did my hair after he finished
doing my hair and i'm thinking
well okay i got to pay this man uh
the guy had disappeared and went in the
back
and then uh
he asked my friend to tell john to come
here and when i went in the back
the guy uh wanted to have sex
and he wanted to give me a head
and said i would have to pain and i said
okay
and uh after uh i did that at this time
i was 15 years old
my friends were 18 or 19. when i came
out the back room they didn't say
anything
you know and and i'm looking at them
like well evidently they have done it
before
you know just to save money or whatever
and me and this guy uh
just happened to uh every now and then
we've gone across each other
and i remember once my mother stayed in
one apartment building and he stayed
across the street
in another apartment uh complex
and one guy the guy came one time the
guy came over my house
and knocked on the door and i didn't
know it was him and when i opened the
door and i seen him
you know he had this funny stance he's
like hey how you doing john
and i looked i said i'm fine and i shut
the door just left the door in his face
because my mother was sitting on the
couch and
i'm not gonna disrespect my mother and
then like i said it's not maybe it
wasn't something i wanted my mother to
know
so and and um so i just shut the door on
the guy
it's like dude what are you doing coming
over my house
to myself and i don't think we ever
talked about him
to any more and i think my mother knows
because something had happened once with
my sister
and i remember my mother comment one
thing about johnny is he's always going
to respect me
and for some reason my mind flashed to
that time right there
you know where um
if it was something i knew she wouldn't
agree with that i uh
wouldn't wouldn't invite her into it i
don't know
i can be wrong i i really don't know but
i just thought that it was uh
the right thing to do at the time you
know i didn't know
um where i'm from things weren't as open
and the era i came from this one is open
today you can see a
two five two fifteen-year-olds and two
eight-year-olds nine-year-olds
saying that they're um
a man trapped in a woman's body or a
woman trapped in a man's body and
everybody'll go for it and accommodate
them well back in my era that just
didn't happen
you know you wouldn't accommodate
anybody for for that you would think
there was a problem
more or less with the person and uh
these days it seemed to be more and more
okay
for people to do whatever they want to
do and how they want to do it
and um that's just the way the world is
you know i i just hope my life can get
better from here
you know and that i can uh
live with whatever and change some
things about me um the street life
isn't easy having sex with people that
you really don't know down here
um for drugs and money isn't easy
you know it's it's just something you do
and it's it's like a uh
a cold down here when you're when you're
a street person
um like
almost like everything goes you know i'm
not the only one there's just so many of
them that
indulge in things because it's part of
the streets
you know like i said you can see people
it's okay to sit on the wall and read a
book and
jack off it's okay to have sex with a
woman
um behind uh one of the missions
all of this stuff is okay because we're
down here so
people think you know it's not until you
start
i started getting a little older
down here then i start realizing this
stuff isn't okay because i started
looking at how the other people are
looking at you you know
and um then you have to look at yourself
and that's what i've been doing lately
is looking at myself and what i got to
go through in life and what am i doing
some of this stuff seems insane that i
have to literally go through out here in
life just to
make a day and some people look at me
like i'm insane
it's like dude are you crazy
and i'll be like i think we're all a
little crazy but
this is life and i'm i'm good
you're speaking so softly oh okay here
you are
well some of the people down here think
i'm crazy and uh
i think we're all a little bit crazy and
uh
it's life though this is life down here
it's life on the streets it's how we
live it down here
and um you begin to believe it's okay
because you can you can uh
you know that you're not the only one
doing it
uh it's okay to buy an outfit
and or or get an outfit and wear it
for a week or two
nobody's gonna judge you you know
because you have the same clothes on
down here
it's okay to have sex with a man or a
woman down here because guess what
everybody's doing it
but you do get judged and and that's
only because a lot of people i think
believe if they point the finger at you
then it keeps the
people from looking at what they're
doing there's so much of that going on
because
a lot of the people i know what they're
doing because i've seen them in the same
circles
but there'll be a lot of them be the
ones
pointing the finger at someone else and
that's just a part of life
you know um like i said one day
things will get better for me hopefully
um
i'm not embarrassed i'm not uh mad this
is something that i deal with in life
it's a life i go with i'm not gonna say
it was all bad
you know this is stuff i got to do down
here um
i had to survive you know
and uh i had to uh learn all the ropes
down here
and i did and it's just the way life is
you know i uh spent years down here on
skid row becoming a part of it
and some people don't understand it but
i i believe it's mainly those
that come down here from um
other areas to do whatever they do
and maybe even to have sex
they don't understand how it's okay
for a lot of people down here to do the
same thing and think it's okay
well it's because that's what we had to
do to survive down here
you know and uh i'm not so much always
like i said ashamed of it i just do it
because you know number one
it feels good number two i'm getting
high
at the same time number three um
i'm downtown skid row and that seems to
be acceptable
you know along with a lot of other
things that go on
down here
i've had several instances with
different men
different women uh only thing that's
never happened to me
is i've never had to get physical
and and beat anyone up or or someone try
to beat me up
you know behind uh any of that but the
strangest thing about
all of this my whole story is this i
have
been to prison uh
countless times from skin row
for drugs and uh
never in the penitentiary
had i had sex with a man it was
different
to me you know uh it's not something
that i was supposed to do in there
and not one year did i ever
but when i would get out
and get back with the drugs and
lifestyle down here on skid row
then it became okay
so i never really understood that how i
can go somewhere where a lot of men
think it's okay and they can't control
their hormones
well it's okay to have a sex i didn't
think it was okay in there
so i wouldn't do it but then when i get
back out here
in society back on the streets
then it's okay you know uh that's that i
have yet to figure that out
how to stay uh straight for three four
five years
in prison around a lot of people that
wanted sex but then i get out here
and i'll do the exact opposite
but you know it's my life
and uh i'm not ashamed of it
i'm kind of i'm kind of
i know one day i'm gonna be somewhere
doing something different
and i'm gonna be able to talk about this
and uh somebody else is probably gonna
learn from
i'm gonna tell somebody what i had to go
through in life
and how i had to survive and
a lot of people probably won't believe
it some of the things i have to tell
them
that were okay with me and that i i did
for money for drugs
it'll be a part of my history but
hopefully somebody else can
uh learn from it because it may be
something they're going through then
and they're afraid to talk about it and
then by me talking about it maybe
they'll think it's okay
because they can see somebody who must
do the same thing
um
i've got a lot of words no that's true
thank you jj
thank you very i don't know how i did on
that no you did great it was beautiful
it's hard to do it all by yourself
without me asking you questions
you did the whole thing all by yourself
well i did huh yeah i didn't say a word
you did he was great
you